[Musique]
jours de rassemblement sur ce chantier
de colimaçons saint leu pour
l'inauguration d'une nouvelle station de
refoulement
le projet comprend donc la réalisation
de ces réservoirs et des stations de
comptage associer un projet essentiel à
voir l'état de sécheresse des pâturages
j en fait d'un chantier qui va faire du
refoulement de l'autre depuis le
réservoir de colimaçon qui est se situe
à peu près à 669 d'altitude jusqu'à
hauteur de 1900 mètres d'altitude depuis
quelques années il ya une forte attente
sur ce territoire avec les
problématiques de sécheresse à prometic
d'alimentation en eau des élevages
l'arrivée de l'eau était inespéré mais
c'est à force d'y croire avec conviction
avec détermination les agriculteurs ont
porté avec le conseil départemental ce
projet le département poursuit ainsi son
engagement dans la gestion de l'eau
études sécurisation de l'alimentation
chaîne de refoulement interconnexions
entre les communes captage barrage
forage les chantiers ne manquent pas le
périmètre irrigué par le basculement des
stores noës représente actuellement 15
mille hectares de saint paul à petite
île un programme ambitieux d'aménagement
hydrique conforme aux orientations de la
mandature de 2015 à 2021
le département a été capté l'hôte de
salazie pour l'amener dans l'ouest nous
avons réalisé l'interconnexion avec le
sud
tout le réseau du sud et pour l'avenir
nous voulons amener l'eau vers le tampon
pour les acteurs du tampon mais aussi à
les alimenter en eau toute la zone est
et nord de l'île depuis saint denis
jusqu'à sainte rose parce qu'il ya les
changements climatiques les pièces de
ses chats sont de plus en plus
importante et nous n'ouvrons d'une
réunion qui se produisent des produits
de qualité avec une agriculture
raisonnée et bien si on veut développer
cette agriculture l'hôte indispensable
c'est pour cela que nous réalisons ces
grands travaux et c'est monsieur boyer
un éleveur heureux de la chaloupe saint
leu qui a conclu cette prise de parole
ce chantier va changer la vie des
agriculteurs des eaux de ces communes
amis de lola
aujourd'hui ça veut dire qu'on aura de
l'eau propre en permanence aux josy dans
les retenues collinaires l'eau croupie
se déploie sur deux ou trois années on
ne peut pas les changer parce qu'on est
passés au pouvoir les remplir
aujourd'hui donc on peut
à ces demandes ont nettoyé retenu
renouveler l'eau et avoir de leurs
propres ailes
rendez vous donc dans un an pour que
tous les agriculteurs et éleveurs de co2
l'ouest puis ce malgré la sécheresse
avoir de l'eau tout de l'année
[Musique]